hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem zweiten teil von
data ariane adrian der letzte teil von
diesem spiel liegt schon jahren der
vergangenheit deswegen verlinke ich euch
den mal hier falls ihr euch denn noch
mal anschauen wollt da war ich auch
wieder super cool mit dabei bevor wir
jedenfalls mit dem spiel anfangen muss
ich noch ganz kurz was sagen zu einem
adventskalender von mir ich habe mir
einen adventskalender bestellt der
irgendwie am 2 dezember jetzt wirklich
auch mal angekommen ist die andere leute
bestellt die schokoladen adventskalender
ich bestelle mir online micro nein ich
habe mir tatsächlich einen playmobil
kalender bestellt wo ganz viele tolle
sachen drin sind und wo wir nachher
seine welt ich habe mir gedacht das
besser spät als nie de
du solltest nach hinten und mülleimer
fliegen ich hab gedacht besser spät als
nie deswegen versuche ich mal einfach
mit euch jetzt jeden tag davon was
auszupacken ich möchte halt quasi dass
wir dann am 24
eine komplette kleine welt zusammen
gebaut haben weil hier auch zum
taktstock ist mit seinem prinzessinnen
und da hab ich mir jetzt einfach mal
gedacht ich mache ja immer täglich ein
video das ich in jedem video versuche
sondern kleines türchen auf zu machen da
wir jetzt gerade am dritten dezember
sind werde ich jetzt heute irgendwo im
video drei türchen auf machen und dann
quasi am vierten dezember morgen werde
ich dann die vierte tour irgendwann im
video einfach so auf machen damit ihr
dann mal schon mal sehen wie das ganze
ausgeht ich habe es gerade türchen 1
aufgemacht hier und in winter hier
hinter natürlich 1 1 war susan erwartet
den namen suchen hatten wir schon das
ist ariana riehen hat sie eigentlich
schwarze haare
40 jahre gefärbt und märchen ersten
türchen batterien
die kommen jetzt in die landschaft
jetzt sehr gut da und irgendwo im video
werden wir gleich natürlich in zwei und
drei auf machen ich bin total nicht so
kleines kind ich weiß nicht wie gefällt
euch das dass ich sonnenkalender mache
alle anderen youtube vermieden was mit
verlosungen und preisen und playstation
und premium und zum scheiß und ich mache
mir sowas mit playmobil vielleicht
feiert ist ja aber wir fangen jetzt
endlich an mit arien also wir sind
wieder auf einem blind date alles
mögliche blabla und jetzt müssen wir sie
irgendwie kennen lernen wir haben die
auswahlmöglichkeiten sieht zu ihr ein
kompliment heißt einfach kombi
luca du bist du natürlich als kompliment
kompliment die kölner etwas kluges sagen
kann er das witziges sagen oder sie
einfach mal umarmen ich würde sagen ich
sag mal was witziges displays xbox live
die auswahlmöglichkeiten jetzt sind
entweder etwas vorlesen oder sie zu
küssen
ich grüße sie
die gentlemen okay wir können entweder
musik hören sehen
wie end
luca das war mal wieder als super was du
hier geritten da ich nicht erwarten kann
die zweite tür aufzumachen machen will
hat bei der zweiten tour bereits den
kalender zerstört die tür ist komplett
demoliert naja wir schauen trotzdem mal
ganz genau wir haben
kann mir jemand sagen was das sein soll
haben wir dabei auch gedacht dass das
ein placement ist für playmobil seid ihr
bescheuert als ob playmobil so einen
typen wie mich an schreiben würde für
ein placement
das habe ich alles ist okay das hier ist
dann schleichen was sie sich um binden
kann
dann haben wir hier sondern rock den wir
hier quasi anziehen können und wir haben
hier glaube ich so ein kleiderständer wo
wir dann ihre kleider
genauso die schleife drum gekriegt und
jetzt klar
der rock sieht aus wie einen
schwimmreifen ok lukas bescheid hat den
rock falsch rum gemacht also wir haben
jetzt
sie sieht jetzt so aus die er in währing
kommt in den akinator ich schwöre es
schließe meinen kanal
mehr ist da nicht runtergefallen aber
wir machen weiter mit dem spielkiste
oder repower notiert erstmals paul bley
welche dings mag ich war zwar komplett
wir können heute wieder irgendwas machen
ich sah erstmal
herr bleib ich machen
da kommen mir jemand schlafzimmers
das war mal wieder ein tolles spiel
ich sage etwas kluges dann lese ich
irgendetwas vor
dann habe ich hier wieder in so einem
schwachsinn dann sage ich wir gehen in
einen anderen raum dann sage ich wir
gehen mal musiker machen dann sage ich
moment
ich habe mich gerade vor dem gesicht
erschrocken ich mach mal einfachen tipp
in kißlegg schon wieder vereint hier
hört die musik nicht auf hallo
jungs die musik ist doch immer an
komplimenten logitech und das lese ich
glaube ja wir machen
gott hat die hat dickes ding in den
händen too much we will get drunk okay
das ist eine tolle info dann geben wir
ein kompliment welt barbecues gilt war
superklasse doktor war geil des sports
sehr auch wieder kurz port said today
das ist ja auch klasse was sie sagt ihr
gefährt kompliment
yes we can take me sowie blabla so super
hier nochmal ein bisschen wein gehört
thekla so zack war dance & living dance
mir da noch ein bisschen wir haben jetzt
zwei möglichkeiten entweder wir warten
hier oder wir gehen mit ihren
schlafzimmer ich würde mal sagen wir
warten jeder mit moro
18 löcher als alles cool war obwohl das
super nasenlöcher berührt ich glaube das
geht schon wieder zu weiter so wir gehen
erst mal woanders hin
dann machen wir den zeit- und schaue auf
mich wartete sogar hier auf sie dann
machen wir jetzt mal dritte kitchen
alles möglich kommen machen jetzt die wm
ich hasse dieses spiel dann an dieser
stelle des videos schon davon bei ist
mache ich einfach mal die dritte
da sieht man mich sieht man
hallo wir haben einen spiegel mit einem
standfuß sogar bekommen freunde also das
ist ja megane als dieser kalender mit
ihrer ehrlichen meinung was ist toller
ein kalender wo ihr am ende irgendwas
blödes materielles gewinnen können oder
wir einen jungen freuen wird über 80
zusammengefasst haben wir nun also im
ersten türchen diese tante drin gehabt
danach hatten wir die schleif und den
rock und jetzt hat und noch dieses
komische aufhänger ding und jetzt hatten
wir noch einen spiegel und das sieht
dann alles bisher so aus unserem tollen
sind 19 also wir haben
wenn euch das video gefallen hat und
wenn auf den kalender gefallen hat dann
zeigt es nur mit einer bewertung dass
sich damit mit dem kalender weitermachen
soll morgen und noch mal zu dem shop das
ist ausverkauft das ist ausverkauft die
münzen sind auf die gebäude ist ein
ausverkauf der holy ist ausverkauft das
einzige was noch bisschen verfügbar ist
ist das shirt mit dem smiley in der
tasche wir haben schon neue sachen
nachbestellt die com allerdings erst so
in zwei wochen an
vielleicht kriegen wir so ein
vorbesteller button einzufügen als
entschuldigung dafür dass alles schon
ausverkauft ist habe ich aber gedacht
ich sehe mir noch mal 700 autogramme
sticker und packt sie dazu das hat noch
die chance mit sticker wird mit
autogramm zu kriegen wir sehen uns
irgendwann wieder alles klar